لكن اسرائيل راويه تبدو منشغله الان بقضيه
اكبر مما تتحدث عنه ايران فتى الابيب لا
تكفوا عن توجيه الرسائل الى ايران والتي
دائما ما كانت تصفها باكبر تهديدا في
المنطقه اخر هذه الرسائل وربما اقواها هي
اجراء مناورات عسكريه مع حليفها الاول
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وذلك شرق
المتوسط مناورات
المناورات والاضخم بين البلدين ستتوظفوا
فيها اعتلى الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
فضلا عن عدد كبير من الطائرات وباستخدام
الذخيره الحيه محاكاه مهاجمه ايران كان
عنوان بارزا وصريحا خلال المناوره صحيفه
تايم اوف ازرائيل كشفت ان التدريبات ستجمل
اسقاط قذفت استراتيجيه امريكيه ذخيره حيه
على اهداف في جنوب اسرائيل والاهداف
ستحاكي المواقع الن هي الايرانيه وسيتم
استهدافها ب 100 طن من المتفجرات
هي المناورات الاضخم من نوعها اذا لا سيما
على صعيد التدريبات الجويه حيث تعرف
مشاركه
140 مقاتله امريكيه اذا تعرف هذه
المناورات مشاركه هذه الاعداد من
المقاتلات ومن بينها طائرات اف 35 والتي
ستحلق رفقه اثنتين واربعين طائره عسكريه
اسرائيليه اما التدريبات البحريه فتشهد
مشاركه اثنتي عشره سفينه حربيه امريكيه
الى جانب غواصه من البحريه الاسرائيليه
وحامله طائرات امريكيه وتجرى القوه البريه
تمرينا مشتركا يشمل اطلاقا عشرات الصواريخ
بعيده المدى من نوع هايم مارس الامريكيه
من منصات اطلاق اسرائيليه كما سيتم
استعراض قاذفات قادره على حمل قنابل نوويه
من نوع بي 52 وعلى مستوى الجنود سيشاركه
ما يقرب من سته الاف و500 جنبي امريكي في
التدريبات بالاضافه الى اكثر من الف ومئه
جنديا اسرائيل
المناورات ايضا حملت في تفاصيلها رساله
اخرى مطمئنه هذه المره موجهه الى او من
الولايات المتحده الى اسرائيل رغم
التخبطات التي يواجهها رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو في مساعيه
لتشكيل الحكومه الا ان واشنطن او لبقاء
الحكومه الا ان واشنطن اصرت على اظهار
دعمها لاسرائيل بصرف النظر عن التطورات
السياسيه الداخليه ولا شك ان الالتزام
الامنيه الامريكيه تجاه اسرائيل باقي
وسيظل بغض النظر عن الشخصيات والحكومات
وهو ما كان سدد عليه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الشهر الماضي بالقول ان واشنطن
تتراجع عن دعمها الراسخ لاسرائيل رغم
الخلافات مع رئيس الوزراء